[Música]
quiero prestar esta charla consultándole
si es que alguna vez han escuchado las
siguientes frases o posiblemente les han
dicho alguna de ellas
dónde está tu media naranja no te
preocupes ya va a llegar o posiblemente
si tienes 30 cuando te casas
o tal vez en tu hijo es lo más
maravilloso que realizas como mujer
o cuidadoso que vaya en tren
recuerden estas frases que más adelante
vamos a saber de qué trata
recuerdo con esta universidad tiene que
ir de un lugar a otro hacer trabajos de
investigación o trabajos prácticos
s porque yo no tenía muchos recursos
económicos por lo cual la mayoría de las
veces tenía que irme aquí
pero en ese trajín veía cosas bien
bonitas que me llenaban desde casas con
diferentes estilos en su chimenea de
madera
o con jardines o ver esas flores que se
trepaban entre sus paredes realmente me
llenaba o el simple hecho de ver un
picaflor libre tan pequeñito pero con
esos colores tan intensos y brillantes
realmente decía como la madre naturaleza
puede hacer estas bellezas estas
creaciones y están ahí en la calle donde
cualquiera los puede
similar sensación sentía cuando pasaba
por aquella de los recuerdos
así le dominó yo a este barrio que me
vio crecer desde niña y que estuvo caché
este valor característico de su
arquitectura señorial y mestiza
y sus calles angostas y tan tranquilas
lejos de la ciudad del ruido de la
ciudad
realmente era muy feliz
es la época con pocos recursos
económicos con mi familia sí pero era
muy feliz porque mi papá llevaba bien
enseñado a valorar la vida lo poco que
teníamos y eso me ha servido bastante
para valorar hoy por hoy más la vida
y fue así que cuando yo tenía alguna
ruptura algún problema en mi relación de
pareja en el cual la relación ya se
tornaba tóxica
tenía que pasar por esos lugares bonitos
por esos lugares los cuales me llenaban
con la caída de los recuerdos
para no entrar en la tristeza en la
depresión
y estás segura de mí misma y no tener
dudas como tuve hace dos años cuando mis
amigos habían organizado el reencuentro
de colegio no
esta lección no había podido ir
anteriormente creo que era el cuarto
reencuentro si no me equivoco
pero ella se aferró y anteriormente yo
no sabía nada de ellas como estaban que
habían estudiado que habían sido de sus
vidas y ahora lo que ver es que he
estado participando entonces cuando
llegué
cuando me dieron me dijeron claves como
éstas han tenido y yo amor propio
porque yo sé que si una persona se
quiere realmente se alimenta para ellos
se cuida para ella
bueno y continuando con esta charla de
actualización donde todas lo estamos
contando que habían sido de nuestras
vidas llegaron las primeras
interrogantes para mí que eran planea
esta es casada
y cuántos hijos tienes y para su
sorpresa
yo me subasta será no no estoy casada y
no tengo hijos
pero me resulta muy chistoso porque
todas estaban casadas y todas tienen
hijos
y bueno continuando la charla
eran como recomendaciones que me estaban
dando después los comentarios no
vinieron y me dijeron
claudia ten tus hijos te realizas como
mujeres que van a acompañar y además del
strong de cuidar
o me decían cuidado se te vaya en tren
y yo no sé si no se preocupe no quiere
contradecirles
pero esas palabras no me molestaban y me
incomodaban porque en ese entonces y
hasta ahora estoy segura de lo que
quiero y de lo que no necesito pero
había entrado en mí en la duda esa duda
en la cual ya me casé diciendo o me
estaré equivocando con mis ideales o ya
tendré que ser mamá o tendré que casarme
y me dormí con esas notas
y como que en la noche al dormir hay que
han estado me haya reflexionado y como
que al día siguiente desperté y dije no
no me estoy equivocando voy a continuar
con mis ideales con lo que yo había
elegido porque quiero hacer varias cosas
sin hijos y sin el estado de ser esposa
porque he decidido este camino de
autonomía y de dependencia emocional y
económica porque yo no lo matizado el
amor como la mayoría de las personas
cree no y reflexión en ese momento y me
recordé de él tan llamado amor romántico
pero qué es el amor romántico según la
española antropóloga coral herrera
define amor romántico como la teoría de
la media naranja
donde todos y todas somos seres
incompletos y la mayor felicidad y la
gloria y la fortuna la conseguiremos no
lo tengamos pareja
entonces recordé que ese era el concepto
que mis amigas tenían que la mayoría que
pensaban que de falta a mí que la mayor
felicidad que faltaba era tener para
ella
y ese es el concepto que la mayoría en
la sociedad en general piensa de un
hombre de origen que debe que no puede
estar sobre el primer instancia que no
acepta su independencia emocional
y espera que
tenga pareja
me casé
y posteriormente tenga hijos y conforme
una familia
desempeñar los roles de género
por ejemplo el esposo va a ser fuerte el
valiente el que va a ser el proveedor
económico de la familia porque va a ir a
trabajar y la esposa se va a quedar en
la casa a cuidar los hijos hacer las
labores de la casa lavar planchar
cocinar
y en este sistema romántico un poco más
ataque
a las mujeres
por qué
en la mayoría ellos no pueden ver que
por agradecimiento se vuelven tal vez un
poco sumisas porque como dependen
económicamente del marido que trae
dinero a la casa para mantenerlos
ya los golpes los empujones o los
pellizcos
ella piensa que son de broma por cariño
pero no es así eso no es amor
el que tengo el pelo de que te insulten
el que no te dejen estudiar o no te
dejen trabajar o más allá que terminen
que con que te den celos o que te
controlen
realmente solo es amor
y estás dejando muy atrás lo que esto
monrovia
entonces sabiendo que el amor romántico
no nos y más bien nos resta ha creado
estos mitos donde los solteros y las
solteras somos clavos en las reuniones
familiares o en las reuniones de amigos
cuando nos dicen
[Música]
soltero y otros 30 15 validar o ten tus
hijos realistas con mujer
él te olvida
a ver si quien me asegura que mañana
pasado yo voy a tener mi hijo y él me va
a cuidar como en cadena pierre webó
hasta el final de mis días
no es justo me parece y para mí en
realidad yo no puedo tenerlo a mi lado
no no podemos tener la seguridad de los
quinceañeros ya tienen tantas
oportunidades de salir del país
11 está sonando un mito que es una falsa
igual cuando dicen se te va a ir el tren
como se te dirá el tren aquí
como que si no tuviéramos productos me
voy a casar con cualquiera que se cruce
ahí por mi camino no nos pueden estar
obligando o presionando socialmente a
casarnos con alguien o estar con alguien
sólo con la presión social entonces
recordando
que los solteros y solteras posiblemente
o inconscientemente no estamos en pareja
lo queremos perder a un hijos porque
vemos que el amor o la felicidad en
cosas como la familia el trabajo los
amigos viajes
paisajes
estudios sobre todo lo que es la
autoestima eso es lo más importante para
nosotros
vuelve como ser humano independiente que
experimentado el amor romántico pero
hecho prevalecer lo que es el amor novio
poder sin útiles para que puedan
sobresalir y no equivocarse con una
persona que posiblemente no es el amor
de sus vidas y no tengan equivocaciones
posteriores
tienen que parecer son los propios
por ejemplo el primero es cuando
terminan una relación cuando tienen
aprende
escenario en tus tiempos
a qué me refiero con eso que cuando han
tenido una terminación con la primera
tenga dolido a través tres meses
la segunda ruptura dos meses o un mes no
sé pero la última ruptura yo hacer un
poco menos pero te tienes que recordar
cuánto ha tardado la primera relación la
segunda relación y esta última en sanar
para que tú misma te puedas reconstruir
y sepas que ya no te va a doler tanto
como la primera vez
como segundo consejo acepte a los
finales aquí no lo quiero con eso
que si ya acabaste alguna relación no
verás en facebook de tu ex pareja no
esperes respuestas en el tarot o en el
horóscopo diciendo volver a tu estrés no
ya no dejas te tienes que soltar lo
vayan a pasado aparecer a otra persona
es un ser humano con escencia con
valores igual que tú entonces tienes que
aprender a soltar
no es justo ni para ti ni para el que
esté revisando su facebook teniendo
contacto con sus amigos o mandándoles
mensajes
direccionados o indirectos no
como tercer tipo
dan de competencias para tu sanación a
qué me refiero con eso que si ya
acabaste una relación ayer o antes de
ayer no entres en la depresión o en la
tristeza
recuperan te tienes que elegir te a ti
misma con amor propio si tienes un hijo
dedícate el que estará haciendo no
sabemos o ha llegado tiempo de darle a
tu familia en vez de darle a una persona
que no valía la pena dedícate a tu
familia estudia con continuar con tu
trabajo continúa con tus estudios
continuamos con el mundo que adelante no
puede decir para atrás la mejor persona
que quieres tú para elegir tiene el amor
propio que eres tú
como cuarto consejo
no te mientras aquí quiero con eso que
en este camino de tratar de estar
recuperando te lo vas a decir no puedo o
no me quiero morir del amor de vida no
no hay mejor persona de darte más ánimos
que tú misma y son mentiras las que te
dices todo fluye todo se puede privar
sea poder
y como último consejo no compares tus
rojos los van a comparar los rojos eran
como los míos con semillas ellas sentían
sus estados como logros que ser mamá
hacer ser esposa se están casadas
y no eran mis logros tampoco yo no les
puedo pedir ellas que sus logros sean
mis logros no podemos comparar los
logros
entonces viendo y conociendo un poco de
lo que es este mor romántico que no nos
suma y más bien nos resta es necesario
hoy por hoy
[Música]
conocer un poco más de las relaciones
conocer con quién vamos a estar y
niveles idealizar el amor romántico no
de que toda la felicidad va a llegar en
una sola persona y cuando tengamos esta
relación de pareja significa que hemos
llegado a nuestra felicidad plena no hoy
por hoy hay que conocer las relaciones
de pareja porque la mente donde 20
bolivia ya hemos llegado hemos superado
más de 110 feminicidios de los cuales
mujeres mueven en manos de sus parejas
que son parejas concubinos esposos
entonces este hecho es un poco
lamentable
con lo cual no tienes que recordar que
en el momento cuando tú te sientas sola
final y te fui a comprar ante un momento
como la noche oscura
es oscura pero brillan las estrellas no
ceden hermosas